bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 14 octobre le sénat américain
donne le mauvais exemple en refusant de
ratifier le traité d'interdiction sur
les essais nucléaires
plusieurs puissances nucléaires
mondiales marquent leur réprobation
l'euro perd au nautic en pleine forme
offre l annonce de la fusion
aérospatiale matra avec une filiale du
goupe germano-américain daimler chrysler
images chocs pour mettre en alerte les
jeunes sur les risques de la route la
sécurité routière veut responsabiliser
les 15 25 ans il fut le fondateur d'une
association pour l'accueil et le soin
des toxicomanes lucien galles meilleur
dit le patriarche dit maintenant
l'espagne tandis que la justice enquête
sur des détournements financiers et des
abus sexuels de concerne à partir de
demain deuxième édition de la
manifestation lire en fête les livres et
la lecture seront à l'honneur un peu
partout en france nous irons à saint
briac en ille et vilaine
les sénateurs américains à majorité
républicaine n'ont pas voulu céder les
arguments de bill clinton pour leur
demander de ratifier le traité
d'interdiction sur des essais nucléaires
ne les ont pas convaincus c'est donc une
défaite pour le président américain
et pour la plupart des autres puissances
nucléaires c'est un recul le président
jacques chirac a marqué sa consternation
devant une décision qui porte atteinte
at il dit au processus de non
prolifération et de désarmement
de plus le vote du sénat américain ne
peut qu'encourager d'autres puissances
nucléaires comme l'inde a persisté dans
leur rejet de toute interdiction des
essais nucléaires sur les conditions du
vote du sénat à washington
correspondance etienne leenhardt avec
aaron d'hermann voilà en vérité une bien
curieuse façon de se prononcer sur un
traité aussi important que celui qui
vise à interdire tout essai nucléaire à
travers le monde à la hussarde en 48
heures avec en tête visiblement à un an
des élections présidentielles des
préoccupations de politique intérieure
les sénateurs américains ont donc fait
passer par pertes et profits des années
de négociations internationales
la majorité d'entre eux sont des
républicains leur premier objectif était
de faire subir une défaite au président
clinton
et sur ce point le contrat est rempli
jamais dans nos tristes
un traité sur les armes nucléaires
n'avait été analysés avec autant de
négligence mais aussi d'esprit partisan
car à plus longue échéance que la
première puissance mondiale refuse de
ratifier un traité qui interdit les
essais nucléaires militaires ou civils
risquent d'avoir de graves conséquences
les états unis ne pourront plus donner
de leçon eux qui ont tant pesé sur la
france et la grande bretagne notamment
pour qu'elle ratifie ce traité
pressentant l'enjeu jacques chirac tony
blair et gerhard schröder s'était même
fendu d'une tribune en commun vendredi
dernier dans le prestigieux new york
times pour appeler les états unis à
montrer l'exemple mais sans succès cet
échec est l'une des pires défaites de
bill clinton sur la scène internationale
une preuve supplémentaire de
l'affaiblissement du président américain
à un an du terme de son mandat
c'est un peu un survivant c'est un homme
politique expérimenté mais qui a connu
de nombreux problèmes ces derniers temps
et cet échec arrive mal après l'affairé
lewinsky au printemps dernier bill
clinton peut toujours affirmer que les
états unis poursuivront leurs efforts
pour une interdiction totale des essais
nucléaires à travers le monde
ces bonnes résolutions contrastent
singulièrement aujourd'hui avec la
consternation générale affichées
notamment par les pays européens
une consternation qui pour beaucoup
d'observateurs laisse présager un
enterrement de première classe pour se
traiter de ratification avant même qu'il
ait commencé d'exister c'est donc peu
dire que l'exemple américain était
important dans ce domaine des essais
nucléaires et il faut rappeler en plus
que deux pays ont récemment rejoint le
club assez fermé des puissances
nucléaires déclaré l'inde et le pakistan
explications et consignes est
l'an dernier l'inde et le pakistan
surprennent le monde en procédant à une
impressionnante série d'armes nucléaires
essais d'armes nucléaires
les deux pays rappelle ainsi que la fin
de la guerre froide n'a pas supprimer le
risque de l'escaladé nucléaire car les
détenteurs officiels de la boum les
états unis la russie la france la chine
et la grande bretagne ne sont plus seuls
dans leur club il ya donc désormais
l'inde détenteurs déclaré d'armes
nucléaires israël et le pakistan sont
des détenteurs non déclarés enfin
l'algérie la corée du nord la libye et
l'iran sont soupçonnés de mener
clandestinement des recherches
nucléaires militaires
aujourd'hui au terme de six ans de
négociations et de conférences pour que
le tri
d'interdiction des essais nucléaires
entre en vigueur il faudrait que 44 pays
le ratifient or seulement 26 l'ont fait
la déception des états unis est donc en
très mauvais exemple
de plus la corée du nord qui
officiellement non pas l'armé nucléaire
et qui pourraient tenter de l'acquérir
et de voir dans la brèche une brèche
dans le fait que les salines ne
ratifiera le traité mais pour les
opposants américain autres étaient peu
importe de ne pas montrer l'exemple
selon eux ce traité dangereux car il ne
saurait empêcher les pays signataires de
poursuivre des essais nucléaire
clandestin de façon certes plus locale
les dangers du nucléaire ont été
rappelés aujourd'hui c'était près de
nogent-sur-seine dans l'aube il
s'agissait d'un exercice d'évacuation
grandeur réelle
après un accident nucléaire simulé sur
le site de la centrale nucléaire de
nogent sur seine
l'exercice avait été conçu pour tester
les réactions des dispositifs de
sécurité mais également celle des
habitants voisins ce qui a permis de
pointer quelques erreurs quelques
dysfonctionnements comme le montre le
reportage de patrice pollet et frédéric
vion claude sicard et christian tu sur
le papier à 13 heures il s'agit
d'évacuer le village de la saulsotte 500
habitants à la suite d'un incident
nucléaire survenue à la centrale de
nogent-sur-seine distance entre les 2 5
km depuis le matin un peu fébriles les
élèves attendent l'ordre d'évacuation
même chose pour les habitants du village
enfin pour ceux qui veulent jouer le jeu
je trouve que c'est très très dur
combien où il y aura un problème un jour
ils sachent commentaire je ne sais pas
comment ça va se passer je vais attendre
qu'on vienne me chercher exactement
comme normalement c'était prévu et puis
je vais suivre la personne qui doit
venir me chercher pour aller au cas les
rien ne se passe pas de cas et après
1h30 d'attentes
on s'interroge pourtant les verts ont
pourtant des trésors
l'ordre d'évacuation a bien été donné
par la préfecture
il y a comme un bogue quelque part alors
ou 5
il est venu voir comment ça se passe
pour effectivement ça a pas l'air d'être
vraiment tout à fait au point
déjà constatée pourtant il est encore
assez tôt dans l'exercice que ça se
passe pas vraiment comme prévu on a
constaté aussi par exemple en arrivant
la sous-préfecture de nogent claque y
avait pas de ligne directe par exemple
téléphonie contre la sous préfecture et
le centre de secours où elle pc
opérationnel
le matin la première partie de
l'opération s'était bien déroulée une
simulation d'hydrocarbures avalé par le
circuit de refroidissement
l' alerte dans la salle de contrôle est
le coeur qui commence à chauffer une
situation critique
avec un scénario qui monte crescendo
nous avons des scénaristes qui donne des
enveloppes au poste de commandement et
les soumet à des situations de plus en
plus compliqué finalement les personnels
du nucléaire ont bien surmonté l'épreuve
la sécurité civile elle a été débordé
qu'on analyse toute la chaîne de
transmission de commandement entre le
moment où moi j'ai donné l'ordre le
moment où c'est arrivé sur le terrain
par qui s'est passé à quel moment et où
vous mettez les points de blocage il y
en a eu finalement en milieu d'après
midi tout rentre dans l'ordre
l'évacuation tant attendu prend forme
les enfants de l'école la population
enfin dans les bus heureusement ce
n'était qu'un exercice
j'ajoute que le projet de loi sur la
sécurité nucléaire et la transparence
dans ce domaine sera présenté par
dominique voynet au premier semestre de
l'année 2000 pour l'industrie
aéronautique mondiale c'est un événement
sans précédent
la fusion du groupe français
aérospatiale matra avec la filiale
aéronautique dasa du groupe
daimlerchrysler créée le numéro trois
mondial dans cette catégorie
représentant 89 milles personnes le
contrat de fusion a été signé
aujourd'hui à strasbourg avec comme
invité surprise
gerhard schröder et lionel jospin
commentaires jean-paul chapelle chef de
gouvernement et grands patrons le public
et le privé réunis pour des poignées de
mains historique
le français aérospatiale matra et
l'allemand dasa fusionnent aussi le
succès d'aujourd'hui illustre-t-il le
rôle irremplaçable de la coopération
franco allemande comme moteur de la
construction européenne le nouvel
ensemble s'appellera eads la première
société européenne pour l'aéronautique
la défense et l'espace
avec 130 milliards de francs de chiffre
d'affaires ce sera le numéro trois
mondial du secteur derrière les
américains lockheed martin et boeing
mcdonnell douglas s'il n'y a que trois
sociétés dans le monde qui fabrique des
avions commerciaux
s'il n'y a que trois sociétés dans le
monde qui fabrique des hélicoptères s'il
n'a que trois sociétés dans le monde qui
fabrique des lanceurs spatiaux des
satellites et autres nous serons de cela
désormais réunies français et allemands
sont prêts à accueillir celui qui
faisait cavalier seul jusqu'à présent
l'anglais british aerospace invités à
rejoindre le nouveau groupe pour
concurrencer les américains c'est en
l'air on le titille la défense est un
secteur éminemment consommateurs de
recherche et développement et la taille
et une énorme force
plus on est gros mais on est la fusion
du jour relance l'idée d'un grand groupe
européen autour d'airbus
ce n'est pour l'instant qu'une
association un groupement d'industriels
ou français et allemand font 80% de
l'activité
les négociations pour en faire une vraie
société de droit privé piétiner elle
devrait maintenant prendre un vrai
départ et quelques heures auparavant le
premier ministre était à léognan près de
bordeaux pour participer au congrès de
l'association des petites villes
profitant de cette proximité
géographique monsieur jospin est allé
saluer en toute courtoisie républicaine
son prédécesseur à matignon monsieur
alain juppé quelques dizaines de minutes
d'entretien privé au cours desquels
alain juppé maire de bordeaux a évoqué
sur tous les dossiers de sa vie si
l'ambiance était plutôt courtoise à la
mairie de bordeaux où elle fut un peu
plus tendue lorsque le premier ministre
à léognan devant les maires des petites
villes de france a exprimé son refus de
tours régimes dérogatoires en matière
pénale pour les élus et pourtant ces
femmes et ces hommes qui prennent des
responsabilités ont exprimé depuis
plusieurs mois leur lassitude devant ce
qu'ils appellent une insécurité
juridique permanente le goût de la
procédure en effet saisi beaucoup
d'usagers et pour tout accident les
maires se voit menacé de mise en examen
enquête david bazié et philippe du mail
jacques duverger merde hostas en gironde
montre la plage de sa commune ou en juin
96 un enfant est mort noyé
baignade interdite mais cette noyade
entraînera sa mise en examen
dans un second temps la justice
prononcera un non-lieu aujourd'hui il a
toujours le sentiment d'avoir servi de
bouc émissaire pour un drame où il
fallait trouver un responsable non lieu
c'est un coup des boues rouges mais on
ne peut pas épongé ce que mes propres
parents ont ressenti quand j'étais mise
en examen ce que mon épouse et mes
enfants ont pu également penser avait
une mise en examen
ça n'est pas une procédure neutre depuis
la réforme en 94 du code pénal qui
pointe la responsabilité des maires en
cas de plainte 800 élus et h
deux collectivités territoriales ont été
mises en examen
en arrivant à léognan aux assises des
petites villes de france lionel jospin
savait donc qu'il allait être interpellé
par ces élus de base
mais pour lui pas question de revenir
sur la responsabilité pénale des mères
je ne crois pas que ce serait rendre
service à la fonction municipale et au
maire que de rétablir en leur faveur
un régime dérogatoire supprimé par le
législateur en 1981 réponse ferme mais
le gouvernement se dit aller coûte un
rapport commandé par le ministre de la
justice devrait faire des propositions
pour un statut de l'élu
nous souhaiterions tout simplement
qu'après l'écoutent viennent quelques
quelques actions qui prennent en compte
qui allège cette ce dispositif pénal qui
vraiment est injuste car dans une petite
commune pas de services techniques et
pourtant que le marché public zone
inondable permis de construire le maire
se doit de tout savoir beaucoup comme
jean andré lemyre vivent avec une épée
de damoclès au-dessus de la tête
c'est vrai que s'il fallait à chaque
fois se plonger dans des textes on
n'avancerait pas donc des fois on prend
des risques on prend des risques parce
que il faut gérer au quotidien il faut
pas attendre pour certains sujets la
fonction pourrait donc bientôt souffrir
du manque de vocations jean andré lemyre
tous 2500 francs d'indemnités pour
assumer ses responsabilités les contrats
multirisques habitation vont augmenter
d'environ 3% la chose était restée
discrète depuis le mois d'août
depuis la publication d'un arrêté de
dominique strauss kahn relevant le taux
de la prime destinée à assurer des
victimes contre les catastrophes
naturelles selon les assureurs il y
aurait trop de demandes en matière de
lutte contre l'insécurité routière il
semble que la france rejoigne ses autres
partenaires européens en usant de
campagne d'information particulièrement
violent qu'il s'agit de faire choc pour
sensibiliser les jeunes aux risques de
la route
sur les huit mille quatre cents morts
par an comptabilisées par la prévention
routière un quart sont des jeunes de
moins de 25 ans avec dorothée cocheur et
guillon faudra nous avons présenté la
séquence de prévention à quelques jeunes
conducteurs
sortie de boîte arrosée mais ambiance
plutôt tendue
la prévention routière joue la carte du
fantastique pour toucher les jeunes
conducteurs les chiffres sont accablants
les 15 25 ans représentent 13% de la
population française mais 25% d'étuis
sur route
pourtant selon une étude réalisée sur le
rapport des jeunes au volant
tous ne sont pas également dangereux on
peut dire pour aller vite car un tiers
qui prennent quasiment jamais de risque
est là un tiers qui prennent des risques
mais qu'ils contrôlent et puis il ya un
groupe qui est à peu près égale à un
petit cinquième un peu moins de 20% des
jeunes qui eux jaillir prennent tous les
risques
or ces jeunes là sont les moins
réceptifs aux campagnes de prévention
routière il a donc fallu trouver une
idée forte pour les toucher
c'est qu'un jeune ça tient pas à sa vie
mais ça tient à la vie de ses copains et
donc on s'est appuyé sur cette
motivation de tous les jeunes
pour essayer de les faire réfléchir à la
façon qui conduisait autrement dit on
leur dit pas attention risque de mourir
en la tension qui risquent de vivre mais
en ayant plus tes copains
des images volontairement violentes
réactions partagées là au moment où on
comprend que c'est direct il ya du sang
on voit vraiment les conséquences comme
moi j'ai vraiment ressenti le cinéma ce
qu'il faudra faire c'est choqué la
personne n'avait entendu réalisme les
spots seront diffusés pendant quinze
jours au cinéma et à la télévision qu'un
jour pour une tâche ardue
aujourd'hui les accidents de la route
sont la première cause de mortalité chez
les jeunes
le médecin du calvados yves godard
soupçonné du meurtre de sa femme serait
bien passé avec ses deux enfants sur
l'île de man devrait séjourner sur ce
territoire en pleine mer d'irlande il y
à plus d'un mois les gendarmes français
venus vérifier cette piste ont obtenu
quelques éléments de preuve mais le dr
godard est introuvable en quête de nos
envoyés spéciaux sur l'île de man avec
frédéric dupuy et jean pierre pasteur
une île tranquille une île du nord
c'est ici à douglas dans l'île de man
perdu là où entre l'irlande et
l'angleterre que les gendarmes pensent
avoir retrouvé la trace d'yves godard et
de ses deux enfants dans cet hôtel
anonyme parmi les autres enregistrent
mal tenu le patron aurait reconnu le
docteur sa petite fille et son fils
grâce à ces photos distribuées aux
hôtels par la police locale
depuis hier aidé par un escadron de
gendarmes de rennes elle vérifie ces
informations l'anc dans cet hôtel est
centrée sur le personnel qui pensent
avoir vu monsieur godard
on leur a montré des photos l'équipe de
l'hôtel ce serait bien qu'au début
septembre monsieur godard et ses deux
enfants étaient bien là alors on
parcourt les registres les notes de
téléphone pour être sûr que ces
témoignages sont sérieux aucune trace en
revanche du voilier de location de 9
mètres qui aurait permis au docteur
godard et ses enfants d'accoster sur
l'île
à l'heure actuelle les enquêteurs
français la police locale continuent
leurs recherches
un appel a été lancé aux habitants pour
récolter d'autres témoignages si la
présence sur l'île du docteur se
confirme ce serait pour les enquêteurs
une première piste depuis sa disparition
il reste que sa trace a disparu depuis
le 14 septembre dernier
trente jours d'avancé sur les enquêteurs
il peut être maintenant très loin de
l'île de man le journaliste
indépendantistes bretons charvy grall a
été remis en liberté il était l'une des
onze personnes mises en examen et écroué
après le vol de huit tonnes d'explosifs
le 28 septembre dernier à plévin en
bretagne en corse l'arrivée officielle
aujourd'hui d'ange mancini
le nouveau préfet délégué à la sécurité
n'est pas passée inaperçue ange santini
avait déjà travaillé en tant que
responsable du circuit du corse dans les
années 80 sur l'île mais la situation
qu'il a à gérer est bien différente
le parquet de toulouse vient d'ouvrir
une double information judiciaire visant
lucien engueuler mais hier cet homme de
78 ans plus connu sous le nom de
patriarche avait fondé une association
des deux toxicomanes
la justice enquête sur des faits d'abus
de faiblesse abus de confiance et
travail illégal mais aussi de viol et de
tentative de viol sur mineure lucien
galles meilleur semblaient avoir disparu
en fait il était très confortablement
installés à barcelone une équipe de
france 2 pour envoyé spécial avec
mathieu verboud et daniel lévy l'a
retrouvé voici un extrait qui sera du
document qui sera diffusée ce soir avec
les commentaires d'hervé rosini la
maison à prix modestement le nom de son
héros musée handel meilleur je vous
parle du meurtre d'un homme je suis pas
s'abîmer
il est intarissable le provocateur
lucien game ailleurs tout y passe
l'argent le sexe est toujours toujours
les toxicomanes
je suis le seul au monde avoir soigné
plus ambitieux que j'ai quand même à 85
% de réussite
qui dit mieux personne encore ne s'était
inventé un personnage tel que le
patriarche mélange d'autorité d'amour
selon lui pour prêter les brebis égarées
dans la drogue
les déchets humains dit-il début des
années 70 l'ancien brocanteurs
toulousain ouvre sa première
communauté thérapeutique bientôt elles
seront 250 des parlements admission
immédiate et payantes travail
obligatoires et non rémunérés
le patriarche devient un empire avec des
holdings l'argent afflue voici l'un des
comptes personnels du patriarche 4
millions de dollars l'état a même aidé
l'organisation jusqu'à 10 millions de
francs par an avant de stopper en 96
mais le patriarche semble en avoir perdu
le souvenir c'est vrai que je dépensais
30 millions de dollars tous les ans vous
savez que certains liens sacrés 180
millions et le gouvernement français que
cela donnait de la merde milieu des
années 90 les adeptes du patriarche
constate que dans ce chalet engel
meilleur serait en train de constituer
un rêve personnel
aujourd'hui une double information
judiciaire est ouverte à toulouse
parmi les plaintes l'une concerne un
viol sur mineure mais si vous le saviez
mais milliers de personnes les centaines
de filles qui me proposait de faire un
bon faut pas délirer quand même c'est
comme une fin de parcours qui s'annonce
pour cet homme de 78 ans pour q2
intention pure et blanche pour un
gardien c'est réussi un eagle mayer
alias le patriarche est aujourd'hui
rejeté par ses proches y compris ses
propres enfants document complet ce soir
dans envoyé spécial
peu à peu en matière de droit de la
famille la jurisprudence évolué en ce
qui concerne la garde des enfants
l'usagé voulait que ce soit les maires
qui obtiennent les enfants ce n'est plus
tout à fait vrai et une décision du
tribunal d'amiens révèle un début de
rééquilibrage bien sûr chaque cas de
divorce et de conflits pour la
domiciliation des enfants est un cas
particulier mais celui dont nous allons
faire le récit avec un big data nourris
et didier rancoeur marque peut-être
cette évolution vers un meilleur respect
du droit des pères me devenir un vrai
papa
norbert attendait cela depuis trois ans
trois ans d'un combat qu'il a mené de
senlis à toulouse où son ex femme est
parti sans prévenir
avec leurs deux enfants
le 22 septembre dernier un arrêt de la
cour d'appel d'amiens a retiré à la mer
son droit de garde est la donnée à
norbert depuis il revit ces décisions a
tout changé pour moi c'est à dire que
chaque jour au quotidien
mes enfants seront avec moi chaque jour
ils expliqueront ce qu'ils ont fait à
l'école chaque jour je verrais grandir
et chaque jour on pourra partager ce qui
n'était pas le cas depuis trois ans
le tribunal considère qu en déménageant
sans prévenir la mère a soustrait les
enfants à leur père elles à empêcher
tout contact entre eux pour l'avocate de
norbert cette décision peut donner un
espoir à beaucoup d'hommes divorcer moi
j'espère que cet arrêt s'il est suivi
par d'autres arrêts dans même sens
mettre un frein à la toute puissance des
maires dans la façon qu'elles ont de
vouloir tout régenter dans la vie des
enfants sans aucune concertation avec le
père qui est souvent très pour la
cinquième roue du carrosse
chaque année 100 amis couple divorcé
dans plus de huit cas sur dix la mère
obtient le droit de garde et le faire et
très souvent séparé de ses enfants
mouvement la condition paternelle
bonjour depuis 25 ans cette association
se bat pour leurs droits pour tous ceux
qui restent séparées de leurs enfants
est exclue de toute implication dans
leur éducation au niveau des allocations
familiales des impôts les rapports avec
le les activités extrascolaires aussi
surtout s'ils constituent la vie de
l'enfant quand on vit proche d'un enfant
eh bien on vit tout cela en étant
séparés on aurait pu le droit c'est pas
normal
norbert a retrouvé ses droits de père il
promet de ne pas bafouer ceux de la mère
de ses enfants
à l'initiative de la mutuelle nationale
des caisses d'epargne un colloque réunit
c'est aujourd'hui des médecins des
psychologues des responsables
d'entreprises et des représentants de
l'assurance maladie pour évoquer un
phénomène presque tabou la violence au
travail encore faut-il préciser qu'il
s'agit de la violence à laquelle sont
confrontés les salariés d'entreprises ou
des administrations
c'est à dire des menaces des insultes
des agressions physiques de la part de
la clientèle conjuguer une tension avec
la hiérarchie c'est loin d'être une vue
de l'esprit et les témoignages sur ce
sujet sont nombreux voyez le reportage
d'emilie lanson et philipponnat cela
c'était l'ouverture de la junte
il n'y a pas eu de détection d'objets
métalliques là j'ai été braquée et la
personne n'a demandé de bien vouloir
vu délivrer le montant de la caisse il
n'y a que vingt mille francs mais le
malfaiteur est pressé de partir
paniqué le pr véronique en otage pour
sortir de la banque
tout va très vite c'est après coup
seulement qu'elle réalise heureusement
j'ai été quand même parce que je pense
que dans ce qu'elle est
ne pas être agressif même je pense bien
de son mot d'ordre c'est d'obtempérer
si le nombre ne veut pas diminuer avec
la vidéosurveillance il s'en produit tu
encore deux par jour dans les banques
mais au quotidien les employés doivent
faire face à un autre type de stress les
clients souvent agressive d'une dame
effectivement qui était fort mécontente
et son salaire n'était pas réel veulent
absolument que je fasse une avance et
s'est présenté devant moi en levant la
main sur moi et voulant me taper si ces
situations extrêmes restent rares les
clients sont de plus en plus précis ne
supporte pas le moindre refus et dans
les quartiers difficiles
les banquiers se retrouvent parfois à
jouer les assistantes sociales les gens
que nous rencontrons sont déjà atteints
par la difficulté de la vie et reçoit
beaucoup plus difficilement le nom parce
que ils ont besoin d'argent parce qu'ils
ont des difficultés financières et ce
sans projeter tout le monde et nous en
veulent un peu quelque part de
participer à ça nous sommes le banquier
aux responsables parfois de leurs soucis
le plus souvent les victimes se retrouve
seul sans soutien psychologique pour les
aider à surmonter ces épreuves ne les
vend lorsque ces personnes ne sont pas
prises en charge comme parfois c'est le
cas où constate simplement que ce
qu'elles n'ont rien physiquement
qu'elles ne sont pas blessés
physiquement et donc on considère que
tout va bien on les laisse à elle-même
et bien médicalement on sait que les
évolutions peuvent être parfois pas
toujours mais parfois extrêmement
catastrophique longtemps taboue la
question de la violence et de plus en
plus traitées par les entreprises
notamment par de psychothérapie de
groupe ou l'organisation de stages pour
apprendre à gérer son stress
une femme française est à l'honneur aux
états unis christine lagarde vient
d'être nommée présidente du cabinet
américain d'avocats le plus important du
pays et le deuxième au monde c'est la
première fois qu'une telle société de
juristes est présidé par une femme 43
ans christine lagarde dirigera un groupe
de 2400 avocats répartis dans 60 bureaux
et 35 pays dominique derda edouard
perrin nous rencontrer c'est un univers
d'hommes ou du moins ça l'était un monde
de verre et de béton dans lequel
longtemps aux étages élevés du pouvoir
les femmes n'ont fait que de la
figuration ou ne furent quant au nec à
des tâches subalternes mais c'est un
monde qui bouge et la nomination à la
tête du plus grand cabinet juridique
américain d'une femme jeune et étrange
r de surcroît est une petite révolution
à 43 ans la française christine lagarde
est la nouvelle présidente directrice
générale de baker & mckenzie
elle règne désormais pour 3 ans sur une
multinationale de 2400 avocats répartis
dans 35 bureaux et 60 pays c'est un
monde dans lequel les compétences prime
sur les a priori et si les gens sont à
la mesure des défis qui leur sont posés
sur le plan professionnel
ces principes de fonctionnement sont en
train de disparaître je crois qu'on
parle d'un d'un vieux monde le monde le
monde de demain je l'espère fera fi de
ces principes de machisme à en croire
les hommes qui travaillent à ses côtés
son élection au poste de pdg fut une
formalité cela fait 18 ans que christine
lagarde a rejoint le groupe à son siège
parisien 12 ans qu'elle est partenaire
associé de baker mckenzie ce qui à
l'époque déjà faisait pour une femme
figure d'exception d'habitude il y a
toujours de longs débats au sein du
conseil pour déterminer qui sera le
prochain président mais cette fois je
peux vous affirmer que dès le départ
elle a fait l'unanimité parmi nous
adolescente christine lagarde rêvait
déjà de parcourir la planète
son métier le savez ne pouvait se
limiter aux frontières de l'hexagone la
voici au sommet d'un empire qui a dégagé
l'an dernier près de 800 millions de
dollars de bénéfices les premières
choses que vous ayez envie de faire
c'est repeindre le bureau changer le
mobilier et mettre votre nom sur la pop
oui apporter un grand un grand coup de
fraîcheur et 1
de la lumière c'est important pour moi
je crois que c'est important pour pour
tous les avocats de la firme de sentir
la lumière elle est le mouvement en
avant sportive christine lagarde fut
membre jadis de l'équipe de france de
natation synchronisée une école de
résistance de persévérance et d'énergie
le secret peut-être de sa spectaculaire
ascension du sport du rugby dans la
perspective de france fidji de coupe du
monde samedi à toulouse le toulonnais
pierre mignoni a déclaré forfait c'est
le joueur de mont-de-marsan stéphane
castaignède qui le remplacera et puis
pour cette journée de coupe du monde il
y a eu quelques records celui là
nouvelle-zélande face à l'italie on va
vous le dirait celui du gallois jenkins
malgré la réussite de ses copines n'a
pas pu empêcher quand même les samoa de
battre le pays de galles commentaires
florent gautreau le peuple gallois et le
monde du rugby attendait ce moment avec
impatience jenkins lui ne change rien à
ses habitudes il utilise toujours le
même sable celui d'une plage de la côte
galloise et il fait toujours les mêmes
gestes avant de tirer mais ô surprise le
poteau renvoie sa première pénalité ni
jenkins attendra alors la 14e minute
pour devenir le meilleur buteur de
l'histoire du rugby ont inscrit son 913e
coin et des passes à l'australien
michael hannah mais l'idole de cardiff
n'a rien pu faire contre des samoa en
fougue et rusé à l'image de leur
capitaine pat lam qui intercepte le
ballon dans le camp gallois et s'en va
inscrire un essai de 70 m les samoa en
rééditent leur exploit de la coupe du
monde 91
cette année là il avait déjà battu les
gallois à cardiff
cet après midi ils ont inscrit cinq
essais et ils peuvent rêver d'une
qualification en quarts de finale avec
un peu de chance les poussins des all
blacks pourrait même s'offrir à cette
occasion un duel contre leurs glorieux
aînés et la nouvelle zélande est en
grande forme on ne sait pas si les
italiens ont eu peur du haka mais ils se
souviendront longtemps de la tornade
noir qui a tout emporté sur son passage
quatorze essais 11 transformations 3
pénalités pour un résultat final de 101
points à 3 et dire que l'entraîneur néo
zélandais
11 remplaçants la correction est
terrible pour les italiens qui ne se
sont pas rassurés à quelques mois du
tournoi des six nations
mais la démonstration est splendide
qu'ils soient déployés volleyer jouée à
la main ou bien aux pieds le rugby néo
zélandais est un autre rugby des faits
terrassé et humilié les italiens l'ont
toutefois emporté sur le terrain du fair
play
difficile de ne pas être subjugué le
président de la fédération française de
football mme simonet a mis fin à toutes
les rumeurs concernant le sort de roger
lemerre au poste de sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france
roger lemerre et bien conforter et il a
toujours pour mission de gagner l'euro
2000 avec les bleus
à partir de demain pendant trois jours
ce sera la deuxième édition de lire en
fête une opération destinée à encourager
la lecture le goût pour les livres avec
des festivals des rencontres des
ateliers d'écriture et de très nombreux
salons du livre c'est aussi l'occasion
de raviver des émotions lointaine parce
que malheureusement tout le monde ne lit
pas et que l'image télévisée ou non a
tendance à mettre fin la culture du
livre mais c'est pas encore pour
aujourd'hui
ainsi jean jacques dufour et frédéric
basket saint briac sur mer près de saint
malo en ille et vilaine ont connu
quelques bonnes heures
en suivant le facteur
saint briac ces deux mille âmes est un
facteur qui comme où se prénomme marcel
c'est un hasard mais c'est bon signe
surtout quand on veut parler bouquin
avec les habitants à l'est la tournée
commence première étape le salon mythe
bonne journée je trouve que quand on a
travaillé toute la journée
le fait de pouvoir s'évader le soir un
petit peu et de la lecture moi je trouve
que ça aide à s'endormir et je suis peu
il est mieux un peu son sa vie
professionnelle
après la coiffeuse à la page l'hôtelière
collectionneuse ici on ne lit pas on
entasse
daniel votre mari vous voulez laisser à
paris où les jetez vous vous n'avez pas
joué les gars des flamands je vais
garder parce que j'espère bien en très
peu de temps 10 minutes par ci et par là
me mettre enfin et non seulement à les
ranger est en fait à les lire pour la
beauté du récit
j'aurais aimé continuer en vous disant
que l'homme des lettres était amateur de
nouvelles malheureusement c'est
impossible
marcel n'aime pas les lignes vous lisez
moi je lis la presse locale les gens
nous de ce sport c'est tout après
bouquin non pas vraiment
les lectures non ce forum mon truc
attention marcel n'est pas une exception
selon les statistiques un gars de la
population n'ouvre pas un livre de
l'année ce n'est pas l'envié qui manque
il paraît que c'est le temps alors j
jamais est possible quand vous étiez les
produits tout faits et glauque ans avec
le temps dira facéties du destin la
bibliothèque est située juste en face du
bar de la mairie un endroit pour voir à
côté d'un endroit pour dévorer
décidément la vie de province a vraiment
des avantages puisque en disant générale
beaucoup de policiers surtout et les
policiers c'est le genre préféré
d'environ 30% des français
évidemment je cause des grands parce que
les enfants si on les laissait faire
qu'il se gaverait essentiellement de bd
lucky luke spirou et dans certains cas
le petit féroce qu'est-ce qu'ils y
arrivent comme histoire et puis ils ont
cherché des titres à dents de sabre et
ça fait peur le tigre à dents de sabre
dans ton pc savoir un plan c'est fini
commencé il y a trois heures la tournée
du préposé s'achève et allez savoir
pourquoi c'est à ce moment là que l'on
trouve la perle françois camionneurs ah
oui je jouerai mais l'iran pourquoi il
ya eu un déclic c'était marqué sur mon
bouquin comme s'appellent ar bobl valery
larbaud il ya des lectures c'est un vice
impuni
donc ça votre avis impunis qui échappe
malheureusement à plus de deux millions
de personnes
c'est en gros le nombre d'illettrés en
france c'est vers la fin de ce journal
je rappelle formation nous avons
développé de cette édition importante
fusion dans l'industrie aéronautique
entre l'aérospatiale matra une filiale
du groupe daimler chrysler lionel jospin
chancelier allemand gerhard schröder à 7
la signature du contrat à strasbourg et
puis avant d'enfermer journal ne nous
associons à la campagne lancée par
reporters sans frontières en faveur de
journalistes détenus
la rédaction de france 2 parraine une
journaliste une journaliste arrêtée en
1994 à rangoon en birmanie san san noël
elle a été condamnée à 10 ans de prison
accusé d'avoir envoyé des rapports anti
gouvernementaux à des ambassades
étrangères
les dictateurs militaires birmans ne
supporte pas que la journaliste san san
boys face librement son travail elle est
libérable en 2004 dans quelques instants
vous retrouverez sophie davant pour la
météo et puis envoyé spécial avec
notamment le reportage sur le patriarche
mais aussi une enquête sur la sécurité
en avion et les contrefaçons des pièces
automobiles à 23h10 comme au cinéma avec
frédéric lopez et puis à 0 1 55 le
dernier journal de la rédaction avec
florence du prat demain à 7h50 dans les
4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra robert hue à
la veille de la manifestation pour
l'emploi à 13h vous retrouverez de
carole gaessler et rachid arhab et à 20
heures
béatrice schönberg alain dit bonsoir
merci
je